[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's a pleasure doing business with you
Sonny everything you know everything
you've experienced has all led to this
is that my desk
yeah why do I have such a small desk
well cuz you weren't that one lurch
isn't destinos you lose I was under
house arrest
yeah guys hope come on we got to focus
on July 6
this is garbage I got it at a rummage
sale ant-man and the wasp get tickets
tomorrow so how long have you been
Antonin again no huh
I just sort of happened like bad guys
like you
[Music]
I seem to mess it up almost every time
[Applause]
maybe you just need someone watch for
back
like a partner
[Music]
back to pen I actually heard what
happened to you you overlooked the
quantum realm that's when his crazy
could be gold so like walks through
walls and stuff so Leo tech now supposed
to take over the world or whatever
who would have believed that in your
hour of need you would turn the house at
me because we robbed you do you remember
that's us
feeling chance you've got this both of
you
and man in the wasp teaming up follow my
lead
[Music]
she seems more intense
[Music]
you go low I'll go high I have wings why
would I go low
[Music]
we're gonna die
hey what'd I miss
we were just tiny I was partners with
Hank on a project called Goliath how big
did you get my record 21 feet you 65
feet 65 if you two are finished
comparing sizes 65
[Music]
you